اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في تغطتنا
لتطورات الاوضاع في السودان مع استمرار
المواجهات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لليوم الثاني على
التوالي في ظل ضبابيه تغلف المشهد حول
حقيقه من يسيطر على ماذا مسؤول في الجيش
السوداني قال ان المعارك قد تستغرق عده
ايام فيما تتجه الانظار الى محيط مقر
قياده الجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم حيث تدور
المواجهات الاكثر شراسه حاليا ونشاهد
صورها الان على الهواء هذا ياتي فيما
اعلنت لجنه اطباء السودان ارتفاع حصيله
القتلى الى سته وخمسين قتيلا والمصابين
الى نحو 600 فيما دعت لجنه الاطباء الى
تغليب صوت العقل وفتح ممرات امنه لاجلاء
المحتجزين والعالقين والمصابين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وقد وثقت مشاهد من العاصمه تصاعد اعمده
الدخان في سماء الخرطوم وذوي المدافع
واطلاق الرصاص
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني اعلن سيطرته على قواعد
ومقرات قوه الدعم السريع في سبع ولايات
وقال الجيش في بانه ان عناصره سيطرت على
مقرات الدعم السريع في بورسودان وكسله
والقضارف والدمزين وكرسي
وكذلك معسكر كرري شمال ام درمان مضيفا بان
افراد قوه الدعم فرو من تلك المواقع
تاركينا كل عتادهم
ونشر الجيش السوداني فيديو لاستيلائه على
اكثر من خمسين عربه وسياره للدعم السريع
في منطقه الدمازين بولايه للازرق
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الفرقه الرابعه تمازين الفرقه الرابع
تستلم عدد 35 عربه
سحاب اثنين عربه
واحد عربه تنكر ماء وكميه من الزفائر الله
اكبر كلام جميع مغارات الدعم السريع
والمواقع الله اكبر
في الاثناء اعلنت قوه الدعم السري انها
اسقطت الطائره من نوع السوخوي من دون
الاشاره الى مكان سقوطها وكان بيان سابق
للقوات الدعم السريع حذر من التدخل
الاجنبي مشيرا الى ان قواته تتعرض لهجوم
من طيران اجنبي في بورتسودان شمال شرق
البلاد
[موسيقى]
وللمزيد من متابعه انضم الينا من مدينه
مروي مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك
نزار بدايه لو طلعنا على حقيقه الموقف
الان عسكريا كنت ارسلت لنا انبات تتحدث عن
ربما مواجهه وشيكا وحشد للجيش حول القاعده
ماذا يحدث في مروي
الذي يحدث في مروي هو الذي بدا منذ الامس
واستمر خلال الساعات الليل وما هو مستمر
حتى الان الجيش السوداني يتمدد على محيط
هذه القاعده قاعده مروي الجويه العسكريه
ويحاصر بالاتجاهات الارباح هذه القاعده
التي تتمركز في داخلها قوات الدعم السريع
هذا هو الموقف الامني والعسكري نتيجه
للاشتباكات وللعمليه العسكريه التي حدثت
يوم الامس في هذه القاعده جعلت هذه
الوضعيه بهذه الشاكله ان تكون قوات الدعم
السريع متمركزه داخل قاعده مروي العسكريه
وان يكون الجيش خارج هذه القاعده لكنه
محيط ويعمل على تطبيق هذه القاعده معلومات
حول وجود قوات تدعم طرفي الازمه سواء هنا
او هنالك تظل ايضا مبذوله بان قوات ربما
تكون في طريقها او قد وصلت ولكنها تتمركز
في احدى المنا هذه المعلومات حتى اللحظه
هي غير مؤكده لكن حاله عدم الاستقرار
وحاله الخوف والرعب هي من تسيطر على
الاجواء هنا في مروي لان الوضع ملتبس هل
ستظل هذه القوات في مكانها هل ستتعامل
قوات الجيش السوداني
بارتدادات عسكريه بقذائف بمدرعات هل
سيتدخل الطيران طيران الجيش كلها فرضيات
الان تظل مطروحه والكره الان يتابع ويراقب
هذا المشهد كنت تحدثت عن نقطه اود العوده
اليها بان كل طرف لديه من يدعمه ويقوم
بامداده بما يستلزم هل ما زالت خطوط
الامداد الى داخل قاعده مروى
عامله خصوصا فيما يتعلق بامداد قوات الدعم
السريع ام انها محاصره بالكامل من قبل
الجيش
منطقه القاعده او مطار دروي الدولي هو
محاط بقوات الجيش السوداني هنالك ايضا
ارتكازات للجيش في عدد من المواقع قوات
الدعم السريع ايضا التي جزء منها خرج من
القاعده او من المطار انتشرت في بعض
المناطق المعلومات كانت تتحدث يوم الامس
او ساعات الصباح الاولى
امكانيه او ان تتمكن قوات تبع الدعم
السريع او الجيش السوداني من الوصول الى
مروي وتقديم الدعم والسند لكن هذه القوات
حتى الان في الموضوع او في المشاهده غير
غير مرئيه الان لا نعلم اين تتمركز واين
توجد ولكن هذه الوضعيه وهذا الالتباس ما
يجعل الوضع في في طور التوتر باعتبار ان
هذه القاعده الان في اي لحظه يمكن ان تشهد
اشتباكات يمكن ان تحدث عمليه عسكريه على
قرار ما حدث يوم الامس هذا اذا ما اشرنا
واكدنا بان قوات الدعم السريع موجوده
وبطبيعه الحال هي ستصر على ان تخرج من في
المنطقه اذا ما خرجت فان قوات الجيش ستكون
في استقبال هذه القوات وهذا يعني المواجهه
المباشره بين الطرفين طيب الان الانباء
اشارت بان انه ما يحدث حول المطار انعكس
على حياه المدنيين الذين بداوا بالنزوح من
مدينه مروي خشيه وصول المواجهات اليهم ما
حقيقه الموقف وكيف تعامل المدنيون في مروي
مع هذه التطورات بعد 24 ساعه على بدءها
كلمه نزوح كما يحدث في في منا
طق
هذه النقطه بانه عندما ولدت معلوماتي يوم
الامس بان الجيش السوداني يمكن ان يقدم
على طلعه عسكريه جويه في عدد من المواقع
والمناطق في السودان تخلص المواطنين منطقه
مروي بان تكون مدينه مرويه احد المقاصد
للطيران الطيران الجيش السوداني
وعليهم ان يغادروا الذين غادروا هم اسر
بسيطه خاصه اسر التي تتاخن او تسقط بالقرب
من قاعده مروي الجويه توجهوا وسط المدينه
خارج المدينه الى مدينه كريمه الى المناطق
الشرقيه من هذه المدينه ولكن بعد ان
استقرت الامور معظم هؤلاء المدنيين عادوا
الى مواقعهم والى مساكنهم لان الطيران لم
يصل مساء الامس ولم يصل حتى اللحظه طيب
اود ان استفسر منك عن عدد من المعلومات
بشكل سريع اولا فيما يتعلق بخدمه الانترنت
هل تم قطعها بالفعل بطلب من هيئه الاتصال
ات ام انها ما زالت تعمل
حتى اللحظه الخدمه الانترنت هنا في
الولايه الشماليه مستقره ومستمره خدمه هذه
بطبيعه الحال كما نستمع الان عبر هذا
الاتصال متوفره الطرق الان سالكه الطرق
البريه الطرق التي تربط بين الولاه
الشماليه والخرطوم وبين مروي والجزء الذي
يوصل الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه الطرق سالكه
حتى الان الخدمات متوفره خدمات الغذاء
والمياه خدمه الكهرباء ايضا متوفره في عدد
من المدن ربما تكون قطعت مساء الانس
ولكنها استعدت خلال الساعات الماضيه
الاوضاع نسبيا هادئه لكن حاله الخوف
والتوتر هي من يسيطر على المشاكل
استمرار اشتباكات واصوات اطلاق الرصاص في
المحيط مقر القياده العامه كيف يمكن ان
تصف لنا المشهد يعني هل هناك هجوم على هذا
المقر من قبل قوات الدعم السريع ورد من
الجيش ماذا يحدث يعني هذه الصوره نشاهدها
في اعلى على يمين الشاشه منذ اربعه او خمس
ساعات لكن حقيقه ما يحدث واعمده الدخان
المتصاعده في قلب العاصمه
نعم نحن في مروي ولكن طبيعه القضيه وطبيعه
الامر هي واضحه بكل ما تحمل هذه الكلمه من
معنى بان الخرطوم الان تشهد حرب مفتوحه
كما قال العسكريون هذه الحرب قد تستمر
لايام في مسرح مفتوح يتمثل في الشوارع
العاصمه القياده العامه المناطق العسكريه
مقر قوات الدعم السريع ليس مستغربا ان
تكون هذه العمليات العسكريه بالقرب من
القياده العامه للجيش بحكم وجود
القياده الرئيسه للجيش اداره الاستخبارات
العسكريه في هذه المنطقه القياده العامه
للجيش في هذه المنطقه اداره القوات البريه
في هذه المنطقه وهي التي قيل بانه تم
استهدافها بشكل مباشر قياده القوات البريه
جيد ما حقيقه ما تم تداوله عن مقتل قائدين
قوات الدعم السريع في شمال وغرب دارفور
قوات الدعم نفت هذه الانباء لكن هل هناك
ما يؤكد او ينفي صحه هذه الانباء
ليس بمقدورنا القضاء في كل هذه البيانات
الان نحن نشهد موجه وسيد من البيانات من
هنا ومن هناك بالتالي التعرض بتاكيد او
نفي قد لا يكون مهنيا في مثل هذه
التوقيتات نحن على العموم ننتظر ونستد
للحقيقه برويه حتى نملك المشاهدين
مالات وحقيقه وطبيعه كل هذه البيانات هل
هي بيانات صادقه هل فعلا تمت هذه العمليات
هل تمت عمليات التي يتحدث عنها الدعم
السريع او يتحدث عنها الجيش السوداني نحن
ننتظر ونراقب هذا المشهد حقيقه
ظروف وملابسات اطلاق سراح الجيش السوداني
للواء صادق سيد كان هناك صور لا ندري اذا
ما تم التاكد من صحتها بعد ان كان اسير
لدى قوات الدعم السريعه منذ ثلاثه اعوام
هل تم تاكيد هذا الامر هذا كان مرفق بصور
نعم الاعلام العسكري وبعض القاده
العسكريين وهذا الامر عبر وسائل التواصل
وعبر واكدوا هذا الامر هو ايضا بذات نفسه
تحدثه وعبر بكلمات وطمان الشعب السوداني
والقى ما القى منه من بيانات ومن كلام
يوضح بانه الان حر وطليق بعد ان كان
محتجزا طيب شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات بالتاكيد سنعود لك في حال جده
جديد ابقى معنا نزار ودعنا
نسترجع ما حدث سريعا فمن قاعده مروي
العسكريه الى كل انحاء السودان انتشرت
اشتباكات داميه ادخلت معها البلاد في دوره
جديده من المعاناه توترات متصاعده تحولت
الى اعمال عنف امتدت الى خارج العاصمه ما
يشي بحرب اهليه تلوح في الافق مع اتساع
النطاق الجغرافي للنساء هكذا تصف صحيفه
الامريكيه المشهد الراهن قتال اشتعلت
شرارته في قاعده عسكريه ومنها استشرى الى
مواقع حساسه اخرى في الخرطوم انطلقت
نداءات تحث المدنيين على التزام منازلهم
بحسب صحيفه اظهرت بعض المقاطع من مطار
الخرطوم الدولي طائره مدنيه تحترق والركاب
في حاله هلع منبطحين في ساحات الانتظار
تايمز ذكرت ان اللجنه المركزيه لاطباء
السودان حتى كل الطواقم الصحيه على الحضور
لاقرب المستشفيات لانهم يواجهون عددا
كبيرا من الحالات الحرجه اذا اتفاق ما لبث
ان ينجح فيندو انقلاب عام 2021 بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيث ظهرت
الخلافات بينهما بعد اقل من عامين
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع التاسيس
الجيش السوداني تاسس في عام
1925 قوات الدعم السريع تاسست في اغسطس
2013 التعداد العسكري الجيش السوداني يبلغ
نحو ربع مليون جندي قوات الدعم تقدر بنحو
مئه الف مقاتل الترسانه العسكريه الجويه
الجيش السوداني لديه 191 طائره حربيه
45 مقاتله 37 طائره هجوميه وخمس وعشرون
طائره شحن عسكريه قوه الدعم لا تمتلك اي
طائرات
الترسانه العسكريه البريه الجيش السوداني
يمتلك 20 منصه الصواريخ
170 دبابه
403 مدرعات سبعه الاف مركبه عسكريه
قوات الدعم لديها اسلحه خفيفه ومتوسطه
عشره الاف سياره رباعيه الدفع الجيش
السوداني يحتل المرتبه الخامسه والسبعين
عالميا في قائمه اقوى جيوش العالم
[موسيقى]
الى ردود الفعل الدوليه حيث قال مسؤول
بوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن تشعر
بقلق عميق ازاء تصاعد العنف في السودان
الذي خلف عشره الضحايا وبحسب المسؤول قد
تكون استخدمت اسلحه خطيره في الهجمات
الاخيره مؤكدا ان قلق واشنطن الاساسي هو
سلامه المواطنين الامريكيين هناك قبل ذلك
شدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين على ضروره
انهاء اطراف الاشتباكات الاعمال القتاليه
على الفور دون اي شروط مسبقه
بريطانيا اعربت عن اسفها لسقوط ضحايا في
السودان بسبب عمليات العنف الاخيره مطالبه
بوقف العنف بشكل فوري ودعت الخارجيه
البريطانيه في بيان لها قوه الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع الى وقف جميع
العمليات القتاليه وان تعمل القياده
السودانيه على خفض التصعيد ومنع وقوع مزيد
من الضحايا والعوده الى الحوار لحل
الخلافات
في الاثناء افادت في الانباء السعوديه بان
وزاره خارجيه السعوديه او وزير وزراء
خارجات السعوديه
والامارات وايضا الولايات المتحده ناقشوا
الموقف الحالي في السودان خلال اتصال
هاتفي واكد وزراء خارجيه السعوديه
والامارات وامريكا على اهميه وقف التصعيد
العسكري في السودان وضروره العوده الى
الاتفاق الاطاري في السودان
وقبيله اجتماع مرتقب للجامعه العربيه على
مستوى المندوبين لبحث الازمه في السودان
وصف الامين العام المساعد لجامعه الدول
العربيه حسام زكي الوضع في السودان
بالمؤسف للغايه وعبر زكي في تصريحات
العربيه عن استعداد الجامعه العربيه
لاجراء وساطه بين الاطراف السودانيه
لاستعاده الهدوء كما دعا كافه الاطراف
السودانيه لوقف التصعيد فورا لافتا الى ان
هناك صعوبه في التواصل مع القيادات
السودانيه المعنيه
[موسيقى]
والمزيد المتابعه انضم الينا من القاهره
الباحث في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح
اهلا بك دكتور بشير في تغطيتنا المستمره
بدايه هل هناك اي معلومات عن جهود وساطه
تبذل الان لاحتواء المواجهات المستمره في
السودان منذ يوم امس
كل التحيه لكم وللساده المشاهدين الكرام
في كل مكان
حتى الان ما رشح من معلومات يشي بان
التحركات من اجل نزع فتيل هذه المواجهه
العسكريه ياتي على مستويين مستوى اقليمي
وهو جامعه الدول العربيه حيث ستشهد
القاهره في غضون سويعات اجتماع على مستوى
مندوبيه الدول الاعضاء في الجامعه هناك
ايضا جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي
للتباحث بشان هذه القضيه اما جهود الوساطه
فلم ترشح انباء عن
المقاطعه الان نتوجه مباشره الى الجمع
الدوري العربيه لمتابعه هذه الجلسه التي
بدات الان
سعيا لتمكين مؤسسات الحكم الانتقالي من
اجتياز هذه المرحله الحساسه في تاريخه
وابدت استعدادا كاملا لنقل الخبرات وبناء
الشراكات المفيده للدولتين وهي تطورات
التزمت بها جميع الاطراف السودانيه وعززه
مصداقيتهم تحقيقا لتطلعات الشعب السوداني
وقد اصبح كل ذلك مهددا نتيجه الازمه
الراهنه حيث تتحسب مصر من خطوره ان يؤدي
هذا الى اهدار ثمار التضحيات التي قدمها
الشعب السوداني من اجل الحريه والتقدم
والازدهار والتي ظلت وتظل مصر سانده
وداعمه له باعتبار ان السودان تمثل العمق
الاستراتيجي الطبيعي لمصر سعيا لتحقيق
التكامل المنشود بين البلدين في مختلف
المجالات الحيويه استنادا لواقع تاريخي
وجغرافي اثبت بما لا يدع مجالا للشك
وبالرغم من اي اختلافات مرحليه في وجهات
النظر حول بعض الامور ان مصلحه مصر لا
تفترق عن مصلحه السودان وان مصلحه السودان
تكمن في مصلحه مصر وان مصير ابناء وادي
النيل هو مصير مشترك نابع من ماضي متشابك
السيد الرئيس الساده المندوبون الدائمون
السيد الامين العام المساعد ختاما
اكدت مصر وما زالت تؤكد التزامها الاصيل
بدعم واستقرار السودان ووحده اراضيه وتؤكد
على اهميه عدم تدخل اطراف خارجيه في الشان
الداخلي السوداني
وتعرض عن تاييدها المتواصل للنموذج
السوداني القائم على الشراكه بين المدنيين
والعسكريين في المرحله الانتقاليه ووضع
الاسس الصلبه لبناء نظام ديمقراطي راسخ
ومستقر
لذا تؤكد مصر على اهميه قيام الاطراف
السودانيه بتسويه النقاط الخلافيه ووضع
الحلول السليمه والواجبه التنفيذ للخروج
من الازمه الحاليه وضمان عدم تكرارها
وستظل مصر تتابع عن قرب وبشكل مستمر
تطورات الازمه الراهنه وتكثيف الاتصالات
الثنائيه والاقليميه اللازمه لتحقيق ما
تقدم مع الترحيب بقيام جامعه الدول
العربيه ببذل كافه المساعي من اجل معاونه
جمهوريه السودان في اتخاذ التدابير
اللازمه لانهاء هذه الازمه بشكل قابل
للاستدامه
اذا تبعنا هذه الكلمه لمندوب مصر في
اجتماع الجامعه العربيه الذي سيخرج
بيان حول تطورات الاوضاع في السودان ابرز
ما جاء في هذا هذه الكلمه التحذير من
خطوره التدخلات الخارجيه في الشان
السوداني وتاكيد مصر على ان السوداني يمثل
العمق الاستراتيجي لمصر وانه يحظى بدعم
القاهره
والتزام مصر في وحده اراضي السودان واهميه
وضع حد
لهذه المواجهه وايجاد حل سلمي وضمان عدم
تكرار الازمه دكتور بشير عبد الفتاح الان
اذا كنا نتحدث عن الجهود
المبذوله
وامكانيه ربما
دخول الوساطه على خط هذه المواجهه
المحتدمه برايك انه هذا الامر قد يتحقق من
خلال جامعه الدول العربيه ام من خلال مجلس
الامن الذي سينعقد غدا ام ان الحل هو
داخلي سوداني
باعتقادي ان التحرك في جهود الوساطه لن
ياتي من المنظمه الدوليه ممثله في الامم
المتحده ولا من جامعه الدول العربيه وانما
من دول عربيه فرادى قد تتحرك المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او جمهوريه مصر انا
اعتذر عن المقاطعه لكن اسلم الى كلمه
مندوب السودان في جامعه الدول العربيه لكن
القوات المسلحه كانت لهم بالمرصاد وتصدت
لهم وتمكنت
من السيطره على الاوضاع وبسط وطرد
القوات المعتديه
تمكنت القوات المسلحه من الحاق خسائر
فادحه بالمتوردين وما تزال تمشط بعض
المناطق والجيوب علم العادات كبيره من
المتوردين استولوا
او هروي الى الولايات المجاوره الخرطوم
اقامه الحكومه السودانيه بحل ميليشيا
الدعم السريع واعلنت انها هو متمرده يتم
التعامل معها على هذا الاساس
لقد فشلت كل الوساطات الوطنيه والاقليميه
والدوليه في اقناع الدعم السريع المحلول
بالاندماج في الجيش الوطني حسب نص الاتفاق
الايطالي
الجيش السوداني اعتمد الان استراتيجيه
القتاليه مع التمرد تحتفي الى تقليل
الخسائر وسط المدنيين
والمرافق الحكوميه والممتلكات الخاصه الى
حدها الادنى لذلك
يلاحظ انهاء التمرد وطرده من المواقع التي
سيطر عليها او يحتمي بها قد اخذ وقتا
طويلا
يجب علينا الان التاكيد على ان ما يحدث في
السودان شان داخلي غير ان جهود الدول
العربيه الشقيقه مطلوبه للمساعده في تهدئه
الاحوال بالبلاد
نطلب من هذا الاجتماع التاكيد على هذا
الامر والتوصيه بترك الامر للسودانيين
لانجاز التسويه فيما بينهم بعيدا عن
التدخلات الدوليه
هذه توصيه مهمه لان المنظومه الدوليه
ستاخذ بها
في حال اتخاذ اي مواقف الاحداث الجارحه
حاليا في السودان
وشكرا جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا سعاده السفير السوداني هل هناك
كلمات اخرى
هل هناك كلمات اخرى من الاخوه المندوبين
اذا لم تكن هناك كلمات اخرى
فاشكر الساده ممثلي وسائل الاعلام وادعوكم
للتشرف اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا لكلمه مندوب
السودان في جامعه الدول العربيه ربما كان
هناك نقطه لافته في ختام كلمه تقال نطالب
الاجتماع
بان
يوصي ضمن توصيته بترك السودان يتوصل لحل
داخلي ودون تدخل خارجي لان هذا الامر
سيؤثر على القرارات التي قد يتخذها مجلس
الامن دون ان يذكره بالاسم قال بان القوات
المسلحه الحقت خسائر كبيره بقوات الدعم
السريع وقال بان التاخير في حسم المعركه
ضد قوات الدعم السريع جاء بسبب مراعاه وضع
المدنيين
وعدم رغبه الجيش بالحاق اضرار بالمدنيين
واعلن بان الدعم قوه الدعم السريع هي قوه
منحله وقال بان كل الجهود فشلت لدعم ودمج
قوات الدعم السريع وبالتالي حدثت هذه
المواجهه
نعود الان الى ضيفي من او ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور امين اسماعيل
مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي بمركز
الدراسات الدوليه اهلا بك دكتور دكتور
دكتور
يعني
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال معا ضيفنا اعود
الى ضيفي من القاهره الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
والدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح دكتور هل لفتك
ما ذكره مندوب السودان هذه النقطه
بالتوصيه بان يكون الحل داخليا انت كنت
قلت بان الحل قد ياتي من دول عربيه فرادى
وليس من الجامعه العربيه
كيف تعلق على من سمعت له
بالفعل ما سمعته الان يمشي بان هناك
نيه للحسم العسكري وليس للمساعي الحميده
او للحلول السياسيه والدبلوماسيه والوساطه
يعني اكادوا الحظ من كلمه المندوب
السوداني بان بانه يطالب الدول العربيه
والمجتمع الدولي دعونا ننهي هذا الامر
عسكريا هو يراهن على ان الجيش السوداني
سوف يجهز على قوات الدعم السريع ويقضي على
ما يعتبروه تمردا او محاوله للانقلاب لكن
باعتقادي هذه مخاطره كبيره لان مساله
الحسم العسكري وحدها قد تجر البلاد الى
مواجهات
وسيناريوهات لا تحمد عقباها من بينها على
سبيل المثال اتساع نطاق الحرب الاهليه
خصوصا مع خروج العمليات العسكريه من
العاصمه الخرطوم ووصولها الى ولايات اخرى
ايضا الامتدادات الج لقوات الدعم السريع
في اقليم دارفور
والانتماءات القبليه والاثنيه والعرقيه
التي تتسم بها ووجود ادوار خارجيه لها حتى
في خارج السودان وارتباطها بدوائر خارجيه
تقدم لها الدعم المالي والتسليحي ايضا قد
ينبئ الحل العسكري باخفاق القوات المسلحه
السودانيه في حسم الامور سريعا لمصلحتها
مما يؤدي الى اطاله عمل الامد العمليات
وسقوط العديد من الضحايا من المدنيين ومن
العسكريين ايضا فضلا عن امكانيه تحول قوات
الدفاع
السريع الى ميليشيا اجراميه قد تقدم على
بعض العمليات اعمال السلب والنهب فضلا عن
اعلان الاستقلال او الانفصال في اقليم
دارفور على سبيل المثال كل هذا قد يكون
تداعيات للتركيز على الخيار العسكري وحده
والتخلي عن ايه وساطه او مساعي حميده يمكن
ان تقوم بها دول صديقه حريصه على وحده
اراضي السودان وتجنيب البلاد وايلات الحرب
الاهليه او اي سيناديوهات كارثيه سؤال
السفير الروسي في الخرطوم قال بانه الجيش
لا يرغب بالتفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع
هذا يؤكد ما ذهبت اليه من انه لا يبدو ان
هناك رغبه في ايجاد حل تفاوضي وانه الجيش
يرغب بحسم هذه المعركه
يبدو ان هناك خلافات عميقه قديمه ما بين
السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان والسيد حميدتي
لان كل منهما يصنف الاخر باعتباره مارق
ويحاول اقتلاع جذوره كليه وابعاده من
المشهد العسكري والمشهد السياسي ايضا
بدليل ان كل طرف يعتبر المساله مباراه
صفريه اما انا او الاخر ولا يقبل باي حلول
وسط على الاطلاق وهذا يزيد الامور تعقيدا
خصوصا اذا ما فشل احد الطرفين في الاجهاز
على الاخر كليه ربما يراهن السيد عبد
الفتاح البرهان بان لديه قدره على حسب
الامور عسكريا في وقت قريب وباقل خسائر
ممكنه قبل ان تتفاقم الامور لكن هذا
السيناريو مشروب بالمخاطر ايضا لان قوات
الدعم السريع قد تنجح في الحصول على الدعم
العسكري والمالي واللوجستي بما يعينها على
الاستمرار في القتال اخرى مقبله وربما
تنجح في تجديد القوات المسلحه خسائر بشريه
وماديه وتضعها في موقف حرج للغايه ومن ثم
هناك مخاطر في الرهان على الخيار العسكري
وتغليب الاعتبارات الشخصيه على المصالح
الوطنيه جيد سنعود لك تفضل البقاء معي
نشير فقط مشاهدينا الى ان هذه الصور التي
نعرضها هي صور خاصه لقناه العربيه
وتوثق الاشتباكات واصوات اطلاق الرصاص في
محيط مقر القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
منذ صباح اليوم وللمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه لو طلعنا على اخر
التفاصيل المتعلقه بهذه المواجهات سالم
الهاشمي معنا من الخرطوم الكلمه لك
اهلا بك وبساهدين الان
الاوضاع كما هي في موضوع الاشتباكات وتجدد
هذه الاشتباكات
ايضا هناك انتشار لبعض القوات في الشوارع
الرئيسيه في الخرطوم تحدث عن انتشار الان
في شارع المطار مثلا في قوات الدعم السريع
وكذلك الشارع القادم شارع شرقي مطار
الخرطوم كذلك هذه القوات منتشره بكثافه في
تلك الشوارع وتحيط بالمطار من كل اتجاهات
هذا يتزامن مع حديث الجيش السوداني عن
سيطرته بالكامل على
المناطق التي
تحدث الدعم السريع انه يسيطر عليها
الاشتباكات ما زالت في حالها تسمع عدويه
لاحتجارات
كذلك القنابل باشكالها كل هذا في الخطوبه
اليوم وانا اتحرك في شوارع الخرطوم شوارع
الخرطوم خاليه على من هذه القوات
نحن نشاهد كما ذكرت قبل قليل هذه الصور
لما قيل بانه مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني والذي تتصاعد منه
السنه اللهب وايضا الدخان الاسود لو تشرح
لنا طبيعه هذه المنطقه وما هي المقرات
التي تم استهدافها
وهل يتواجد بها احد
هذه هي المقرات هي والمقرات القياده العمل
للجيش السوداني فيها القياده البريه وهي
التي احرقت بالكامل في الصور التي وردت
فجر اليوم فيها ايضا قياده الجويه فيها
ايضا البحريه فيها ايضا العمليات كل هذه
موجوده في
في هذه المنطقه العسكريه بالكامل للقيام
العامه للجيش السوداني تحدث الدعم السريع
على انه يسيطر على هذه القياده ثم جاء
الجيش السوداني ونصر هذا الامر قال انه هو
من يسيطر على القياده العامه للجيش
وليس هنالك الا جيوب بسيطه جدا من
المتمردي الدعم السريع بحسب وصفه الفلاني
في اطراف القياده العامه وسيتم حجمهم في
اسرع وقت ممكن الجيش السوداني كذلك في
بيان ليوم صباح اليوم تحدث على هذه المهمه
الشعب السوداني بشريات في
الساعات القليله القادمه طيب الان نتابع
نحن على الهواء مباشره بيان لقوى الحريه
والتغيير يطالب بنبج خطاب الكراهيه وتاجيج
الحرب وايضا يدعو قياده الجيش والدعم
السري الى تحكيم صوت العقل هل صدرت ردود
فعل اخرى غير ما ذهب اليه بيان قوى الحريه
والتغيير وكيف
رصدتم ردود الفعل على المستويين السياسي
والشعبي منذ يوم الامس وحتى الان على هذه
المواجهات المستمره
نعم ردود الفعل تباينت لكن كلها تتحدث على
انه يجب ان يحكم صوت العقل
ولا يتعامل
لا تتعامل هذه الاطراف بهذه الحده وبهذه
الطريقه لانه في النهايه لا رابح من هذه
الحرب
والحرب ليست خيارا جيدا بكل تاكيد هكذا
تحدثت هذه الاطراف وهي تشدد على انه يجب
ان يتدخل كذلك المجتمع الدولي
والوسطاء في البحث حل عن لحل هذه القضيه
التي تعتبر هي متفاقمه وفي تزايد وعلى
الارض ايضا الاشتراك ما زالت على حالها ان
لم تكن اكثر شراسه طيب في ظل هذه
الاشتباكات واستمرارها يعني اعمده دخان
شوارع خاليه انتشار مسلح كما ذكرت وذوي
المدافع
واجهزه الرصاص ماذا يفعل المواطن السوداني
كيف يتدبر احواله الانباء كانت تشير الى
ان الجميع التزم منزله منذ يوم الامس كيف
هي ربما امدادات المياه الكهرباء الانترنت
في العاصمه
معممه هناك انقطاع لسياره الكهربائي منذ
يوم امس من الحاديه عشره الان يعني اكثر
من 24 ساعه من انقطاع هذا التيار
الكهربائي عن كل اجزاء او غالبيه اجزاء
ولايه الخرطوم عدم مناطق يسيره جدا بقيه
المناطق كلها انقطع عنها التيار الكهربائي
كذلك انقطاع في الامداد المائي كذلك
للمنازل كل هذه الامور تجعل المواطن
السوداني على ما هو عليه من توتر حقيقي
وعلى ما هو عليه ايضا من هذه الانفجارات
وذوي
المدافع ايضا هنالك القطاع السياره
الكهربائي يعدم وجود امداد مائي كل هذه
امور تدعو المواطن السوداني او تجعله قلقا
الى حد كبير الحاجات الاساسيه هل هناك
متاجر مفتوحه يتزود بها المواطن خصوصا
بانه هناك خشيه من استمرار هذه المعارك
حسب ما اكد الجيش السوداني بان هذه
المعارك قد تستمر لايام لحسم المعركه
لصالحه
هناك بعض المت
مفتوحه بالفعل هناك متاجر المفتوحه في
مناطق مختلفه من الولايه لكن هذه المتاجر
كلها في داخل الاحياء خارج الاحياء كل
الاسواق مغلقه الاسواق الرئيسيه مغلقه كل
المناطق المناطق التجاريه الكبرى في ولايه
الخرطوم كلها مغلقه حتى هذه اللحظه شكرا
جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه كنت معي من الخرطوم
واعود الى ضيفي من القاهره الدكتور بشير
عبد الفتاح دكتور بشير برايك ما المصير
الذي ينتظر السودانيين في ظل حاله عدم
اليقين التي تعيشها البلاد الان
نحن نتحدث عن دوله تتسم بتنوع عرقي واثني
لافت وللاسف الشديد هناك ضعف في السلطه
المركزيه هناك تدخلات خارجيه من كل حدب
وصوب وهناك سوابق لانفصال اجزاء من هذه
الدوله وتشكيل كيانات مستقله ودول هناك
ايضا ميليشيات مسلحه تعمل لحساب اطراف
داخليه
وتتلقى دعما وتوجيها ايضا من اطراف خارجيه
لذلك هذه البيئه تعتبر بيئه ملغومه للغايه
مع نشوب توترات كتلك التي تعصف بالسودان
اليوم يمكن لهذه البيئه الملغومه او
الملتهبه ان يعني تشهد سيناريوهات كارثيه
اسواؤها الحرب الاهليه
والاسوا ايضا ان نشهد انقسامات او حركات
انفصاليه جديده تمزق وحده التراب السوداني
لذلك ما لم يتم احتواء هذه المواجهات اسرع
وقت ممكن سواء من قبل بعض الحكماء في
الداخل او بوساطه اطراف عربيه او تدخل
المجتمع الدولي
السيناريو الاسود سيكون هو الاقرب سواء
حرب اهليه او انفصال ومن شان الاوضاع في
السودان الغير مستقره ان تؤثر على الامن
الدولي قاطبه السودان مطله على البحر
الاحمر
هذه النقطه التي اشرت لها وناخذ راي ضيفنا
الذي ينضم الينا من الخرطوم دكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا بك دكتور
امين لا ادري اذا كنت استمعت الى ما ذهب
اليه الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح من انه
استمرار هذه المواجهات ستذهب بالسودان الى
المجهول وربما حرب اهليه من جديد وهو الذي
اختبرها
وعرف مرارتها هل انت متشائم ام متفائل حيل
ايجاد حل سريع قبل ان تذهب الامور الى
ما لا تحمد عقبه
طبعا السودان معروف انه هو
يتكون من قبائل واسميات ولديه اتصال مع
دول الجوار هذا التعقيد استمرت هذه الى
الاختراعات وخرجت من العاصمه الى الولايات
والمناطق المتاهمه ربما يشعل الاقليم كله
السودان فقط نعلم انه القبائل المكونه
للدعم السريعه لديها امتدادات ايجاد
واقرير الوسطى ومالي والنيجر وبوركينا هذا
عمق افريقيا كبير وايضا داخل السودان
هنالك قبائل بيدارفور ايضا جنب تنضم الى
السلام حتى الان لذلك الافضل هو يصاب هذا
الصراع الاحتكار العقد الان الجامعه
العربيه اجت لها شده الامم المتحده على
الانسان الامين العام راشد
القاده العسكريه يجب ان يعلموا ان
زرار بدا الحرب سهل ولكن اضافه يكون صعب
جدا تدخل فيه بعض الاشياء النفسيه وبعد
الاشياء الميدانيه لذلك نحن نجد عبر الحكم
وعبر هذه القناه ان يحتكم الجميع لصوت
العقلي حتى لا تجديد
الخسائر البشريه والماديه والبنيه التحتيه
ويتطور الامر الى اكثر من ذلك اذا خرج من
محيط العاصمه الى الولايات الاخرى
لكن اسمح لي ان افتح قوس يعني انه قد يذهب
البعض للقول بانه وجود قوتين عسكريتين في
دوله واحده
قد ربما يساهم في تعزيز حاله عدم
الاستقرار
الان استمعنا الى مندوب السودان في جامعه
الدول العربيه الذي قال بانه فشلت كل
الجهود لدمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش
وبالتالي الان تم اعلانها هذه قوه يعني
منحله
حسب ما فهمناه بانه السفير الروسي نقل
السفير الروسي في الخرطوم نقل عن الجيش
عدم رغبته في التفاوض مع قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش هو اكثر جهه تعلم حقيقه
امتدادات قوات الدعم السريع داخل وخارج
السودان كما تفضلت اذا كانت هذه المعلومات
كلها معروفه وحاضره لدى الجيش لماذا هناك
رغبه في حسم هذه المعركه عسكريا وليس من
خلال طاوله الحوار من وجهه نظركم
بدايه
كانت هنالك بعض من الجانبين
احدثت تاثيرات نفسيه
واصبحت الامور تميل الى الى الانتقام والى
الانتصار للذات هذه واحده من الخطوره في
مثل هذه المعارك اللي بتكون محليه في داخل
دوله واحده اذا كان هناك عدو خارجي الامور
مقدور عليها لكن عندما يكون صراع الاخوه
وابناء العم
وقوات كانت موجوده مع بعضها البعض ويمكن
واحده من الاخطاء النظام السابق مثل هذه
القوات وتسليحه ورعايتها الى ان اصبحت
توازي او او تساوي احيانا الجيش الوطني
لذلك الامور النفسيه حاضره لكن اعتقد انه
هذا الرد ربما يكون هنالك اخر في الساعات
القادمه
ايضا مساله ترجيح الكفر كقوات مسلحه ايضا
كرامه الدوله وكرامه المسلحه احيانا ترجيع
صالح ابو هذا المسلحه ومن ثم ياتي الجميع
الى الى احضان الوطن وليس العبد هذه واحده
ايضا من الاعمال ممكن تؤثر في علم التفاوض
فيما يتعلق بتصليحات قوى الحريه والتغيير
كان هناك
اتهامات
لمن اسموهم بفنون النظام السابق بانهم هم
من قاموا بالتعبئه لهذه الحرب هل تتفق او
تختلف مع هذا الطرح وما اذا كانت يعني هذه
الفنون لديها القدره للتاثير يعني سواء
كان في المكونين العسكريين او حتى
المكونات المدنيه
في تقديري ليس هذا وقت مثل هذه التصريحات
نظام السابق انتهى بقيام ثوره ديسمبر
وتلاشى تماما وحتى وان كان هنالك اعلام
لهم او اي تحركات لا اظنها تؤثر في قوات
مسلحه نظاميه او تؤثر في هكذا مشهد او
تحرز الدعم السريع على الغور السياسيه
الان ان تقف المسلحه وليس ان تجعل النيران
الخلافات مره اخرى هذا هو المراد وحتى
الضيوفوا في القنوات يجب ان يعلموا انهم
يتحدثون للعالم باسم السودان وليس باسم
اشخاصهم او او احزابهم هذا هو السودان
دعنا دعنا نشاهد هذه الصور التي نبثها
الان
لعدد من
المحتجزين من قوات الدعم السريع لدى الجيش
ويتحدثون عن المعامله التي يتعرضون لها من
الجيش
وبلغ الاسره
الحمد لله بخير وعافيه
ما عندها
وفي العريب
الحمد لله
محمد
الحمد لله والصلوات المسلحه
معانا في التعامل
هنا كل التعامل واخواننا
الناس تسلم
اذا شاهدنا معا دكتور امين هذه الصور
للاسرى من قوات الدعم السريع وشهاداتهم
برايك صور من هذا النوع كيف سيكون تاثيرها
هل ستساهم في تاجيج الصراع ام عكس صوره
افضل عن الجيش
تدخل طبعا في الحرب النفسيه
اولا من الله الروح المعنويه للقوات
المسلحه ان السيطره الموقف وننتهي من حرب
البيانات
الاعلاميه ايضا بتوري اخواننا في الدعم
السريع
هم سودانيين الان بتلقوا معامله طيبه لا
يوجد اي عمليات انتقاميه وانما نحن كلنا
سودانيين الاخلاق لكن من يضع يهودي معامله
طيبه بتكون موجوده من جانب اخر قد يفكر
اخرين انه مثل هذه الصور تؤجج الاوضاع
هنالك باعتبار عندهم اطوالهم اسرى وكذا
لكن بالعكس لا عندنا خبرتنا العسكريه
دائما لما العسيري يتعامل معامله كويسه
يكون له اثر ايجابي ونتمنى انه كل الاخوان
سواء كان في القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
الان يتم تبادل الاسئله بسرعه جدا حتى
يطمئن الجميع وتكون هنالك صيغه وننتهي من
اجل الازمه
لدينا الان صور جديده
سنبثها بعد قليل ونعلق عليها سويا ستجهز
هي احتفالات
للجيش السوداني بتحقيق انتصارات كان اكد
الجيش
السوداني بانه حقق الكثير من الانتصارات
وربما هذه الصور التي شاهدناها قبل قليل
من اعتقال عدد كبير من قوات افراد قوات
الدعم السريع
والسيطره على عدد من المواقع تدعم هذا
الامر
نذكر فقط باننا ما نشاهد الان على الشاشه
هي صور مباشره خاصه بقناه العربيه
لنتائج الق صف المستمر منذ الصباح اليوم
لمبنى محيط القياده العامه للجيش اذا هذه
الصور التي تحدثنا عنها هي احتفالات
الله اكبر هذه الاحتفالات لقوات الجيش
السوداني
لا نعرف تحديدا المنطقه
اذا الزملاء يؤكدوا لي بان هذه الصور من
بورت سودان وتاتي في اعقاب سيطره قوات
الجيش السوداني على مقر لقوات الدعم
السريع نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر يا سعادتك
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر ابشر ابشر يا سعد ابشر ابشر
ابشر ساعد ابشر ابشر يا سعد ابشر مبروك
والله مبروك مبروك
[موسيقى]
يا سعادتك
وهذه ايضا صور قناه العربيه الخاصه
والتي ترصد اثار القصف الذي استهدف محيط
مقر القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
واستمرار الاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه
وتصاعد السنه اللهب والدخان اعمده الدخان
في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم منذ صباح اليوم
كانت هناك مواجهات
كثيفه بين قوه الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني الذي اكد انه ما زال يسيطر على
مقر القياده في حين قالت قوه الدعم بانها
قصفت هذه المقرات وانها تسيطر عليها وما
زالت الى الان تسمع اصوات
الرصاص وذوي المدافع في المنطقه على كل
حال اذا مجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي يعقد
جلسه طارئه اليوم لمناقشه تطورات الاوضاع
في السودان واعود الى الريف من القاهره
الباحث في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح
دكتور بشير يعني واضح بانه هناك حرب
معلومات هناك حرب اعلاميه لا تقل اهميه عن
الحرب العسكريه التي تدور راحاها في
الخرطوم وبورتسودان ومناطق اخرى برايك الى
اي مدى سيكون
لهذه الحرب الاعلاميه تاثير في ربما النيل
من معنويات طرف على حساب طرف اخر
ما تفضلت بالاشاره اليه هو حروب الجيلين
الرابع والخامس وهذا النوع من الحروب
يستخدم تكنولوجيا حديث او متطوره للغايه
لبث الشائعات والافكار التي يمكن ان تؤثر
في معنويات الخصم كما يمكن ان تبعث روح
التفاؤل لدى مؤيدي من يقوم بشان هذه الحرب
ولا تخلو حروب اليوم من مثل هذا النوع من
الحروف فرصه انا ساعطيك فرصه اعذرني
ساعطيك فرصه لتجيب على هذا السؤال لكن نود
ان نعرض فيديو في سياق ما نتحدث عنه
احتفالات قوات الدعم السريع داخل قاعده
مروي والتاكيد على انها تسيطر على المطار
والقاعده العسكريه نتابع ثم نعود لك
المسلحه انه ينضفوا وينحاز لهذا العمل
الوطني الاصيل الغيوب لذلك
هذا البرهان الله
لمن اجي من دارفور اجي مروري احس انه انا
في بلدي وسط اهلي
الله اكبر
اعود لك دكتور بشير عبد الفتاح لتعلق لنا
على ما طرحناه من موضوع هذه الحرب
الاعلاميه كل جانب ينشر مقاطع فيديو تؤكد
بان له اليد العليا وانه حقق انتصارات هنا
وهناك
لان لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت السلاح عزيزي
الاسلحه هو الذي يتحدث الان في السودان
الحديث عن المبادرات والحوارات والمفاوضات
غائب تماما بدليل وكما ذكرنا من قبل في
هذا اللقاء ان مندوب السودان لدى الجامعه
العربيه اشار الى ان الحسم العسكري هو سيد
الموقف وهو الخيار الاول والاخير ومن هنا
يحاول كل طرف ان يظهر مدى تفوقه ونجاحاته
وانجازاته العسكريه الميدانيه على الارض
لانه يامل في ان يساعده ذلك على حشد
المؤيدين لا سيما واننا بصدد استقطاب
سياسي عسكري لافت في المشهد السوداني الان
كل طرف يريد ان يقدم نفسه على انه ممثل
المؤسسه العسكريه الوطنيه في البلاد تريد
قوات حماته ان تنفي عن نفسها انها ميليشيا
مسلحه مارقه بينما الجيش السوداني يريد ان
يقول انني الوطنيه العسكريه التي يجب ان
يلتف من حولها الجميع وكل طرف يراهن على
ان الانجاز الميداني العسكري على الارض هو
الذي سيحسم الامور في نهايه المطاف واذا
ما استمر الامر على هذا النحو سوف تتدحرج
الامور الى حرب اهليه كلفتها البشريه
والماديه ستكون فائقه للغايه لان حرص كل
طرف على تحصيل المكسب العسكري الميداني
سيجعله يمعن في استخدام القوه العسكريه
الباطشه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور بشير داهمنا
الوقت هذه التغطيه مستمره على قناه
العربيه لكن نبقى مع هذه الصور التي
بصوها لكم وهي صور خاصه بقناه العربيه
والتي تبين محيط مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني والذي حدثت هناك اشتباكات عنيفه
منذ الصباح اليوم وهذه اعمده الدخن في
سماء العاصمه الخرطوم منذ الصباح اليوم
وما زالت الاشتباكات متواجدا نشكر ضيوفي
الذين كانوا معي من القاهره ومن الخرطوم
الدكتور امين اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي بمركز دراسات الدوليه وايضا
من القاهره الباحث في مركز الاهرامات
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الدكتور
بشير عبد الفتاح تغطيتنا مستمره معكم
مشاهدينا على راس الساعه لكن الان نتحول
الى الزميل نايف الاحمري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات